by this axe
i ruled
[Music]
welcome to another exciting episode of
kos and today i bring you
spider-man's number one villain
the ace in his role gallery i bring you
xm studios 1 4
green goblin
what more can i say harry osborne
is the green goblin and i know to peter
parker who is spider-man
that came as an incredible shock to him
it was an outstanding issue it was a
fantastic
read and the reason why i love the green
goblin so much is because he's a mix of
so many characters rolled up into one
he's a mix of the joker batman
and tony stark which is iron man and
let me give you why i say these things
first before he took the serum that
turned them into a psychotic maniac
he was a very and he still is a very
successful
businessman who runs
oscorp which is kinda like lexcorp
and lex luther but oscar so we're going
to say like stony
and stock industries right or
the wayne foundation financially
affluent but with the gadgets
that are particularly very ingenious
like the batarangs that he has
seen bats right
razorbacks that he tosses
so and pumpkin bombs
that he has in his hand
he is an incredible
unique character and he has been a thorn
in the side of peter parker aka
an amazing spider-man for a very long
time
i'll never forget the time that he
captured peter parker revealed
his identity to peter and he had
peter tied up to a chair it's one of the
iconic covers
in uh marvel's history
and this is the reason why i got this
statue
because if you look you can see him
holding
the goblin mask as harry
yells at parker puny parker
never forget that you know it's an
incredible read
it's an incredible book it's an
incredible character
and this is an incredible statue so
let's get into this statue let's
fall into this statue where we can see
everything that this statue has to offer
from the base
see now what i love about the statue the
most
is it has the glider in motion now how
are you going to get something that
flies in air in motion
with a statue well you can prop it
up on a base and it looks like it's
taking
off which it does and this is the most
intricate glider that i've seen
from a green goblin statue to this date
the face is incredible the smoke cloud
as you can see
the orange which turns to yellow which
turns to gray which turns to white smoke
at the end from the blue nozzle from the
flames
from the inside where you can see the
blue yellow and orange
of the turbines the lifters under the
gliders
they have lifted they have ailerons and
aelon
right there incredible stuff
you can see the leather bag with the
whole
goblin outfit the outfit is incredible
it is done so well you can see the chain
mail throughout the whole costume all
the way
up to the the paddings on his
uh his uh like his um what's those parts
those vital parts
right so he has paddings all over
to protect him this costume is well
thought out
and the way that xm does their statues
which i love
they take a little liberties here but
still keeping it comic accurate
and they also give you a wonderful
plaque that goes with the statue
so when you display a statue it has that
plaque option
it comes with his
signature zap finger
which i love the most when he's fighting
spider-man he hits him with that
electrical zap and stuns him
well this is the point in the video when
i'm gonna ask you to
like follow and subscribe and also
hit that join button hit that joy button
you know where that join button is that
join button is right below
so you hit the join button and you can
follow me on the realm of iron lord's
podcast
and also go to lordsofgaming.net where
we have a ton of writers
we also have a series going on with get
to know your lords
so you get writers and the lords
bringing up new
topics and questions that you want to
know about
you can also find me on dcx fridays
at 9 00 pm stick around
watch this video and see this statue
in all its glory without me talking
and more close-ups on the star
of this show see you next week when i
bring you
more from spiderman's
road gallery
[Music]
stay collecting
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
i rule
[Music]
you